all right the big day is here we are
finally doing the Rubin Report fan show
in case you missed it a couple weeks
back I had asked you guys to let me know
why I should interview you and I got to
tell you guys you did not disappoint me
we got almost 1200 responses within a
week and ended up selecting 20 of you
instead of the original five that we had
intended we're going to release these
over the course of a couple weeks each
video with a few eight to ten minute
interviews many of you guys wrote
incredible essays on what's going on in
your life and in your corner of the
world I promise you that we read every
single entry it took us a long time and
it was incredibly difficult to make the
decision of who to choose we did our
best to pick an eclectic mix of people
from all over the world
on a personal note I just want to say
how truly truly awed and humbled I am by
your submissions the fact that you guys
watch this show share it with friends
and family and are engaging in the
battle of ideas yourself really makes
putting myself out there worthwhile I'm
honored really to have such an
incredible fan base that not only is
connecting with me but with each other
as well clearly you guys all recognize
that we're in this together
and that talking about the important
issues honestly is the only way to move
forward as part of the human race all
right then the first ever Rubin Report
fan show is here let's roll all right
I'm on with Sophie in London Sophie
how's it going I'm amazing thank you so
much for having me tonight Dave yeah my
pleasure
all right so I saw on Twitter you're
very excited to talk to me I have a
whole list of things that you had
written in originally about but I sense
that more than anything else you want to
talk about feminism as am i right
yeah my favorite topic it's delicious
delicious all right well let's let's
dive right in what are your feelings
about feminism in 2016 well Dave the
problem is feminism 2016 isn't the
feminism that once was I think I think
we know from Mario you know Peleus and
christina hoff sommers who promoted it
amazingly well this idea that modernist
feminism has become akin to Matt
ting it has it has and I myself having
been brought up in a family of mostly
females with my dad of course bless his
heart I know the value of being a strong
independent woman as cliche as it sounds
and that doesn't involve safe spaces
that doesn't involve shying away from
debate you know what involves it
involves being equal to a man it
involves working to be equal so you know
everything about this whole safe space
concept is extremely dangerous because
these people these people these students
universities like myself they will be
subject to morally coddling to being
told they are victims all the time and I
imagine you are being constantly told
you're a victim what is that going to do
to your mentality that is extremely
damaging and that is what modal
modernist feminism is doing to women all
the time and it's depressing because we
are meant to be for gender equality so
why are we telling these women why are
we telling females everywhere that you
can't do this that this mystical force
the patriarchy is supposedly oppression
oppressing us and now I say this
obviously patriarchy is a serious issue
in countries such as the least and India
for instance but in the West you know I
can walk out my house without a male
minder and it's and it's fine you know I
don't have this I don't have this
oppression on me yeah so you're telling
me you're safe when you walk out of your
house in London you can make it to the
store without a man and you can do that
on your own you know what I mean
sometimes I do get a bit of a panic
attack coming up because I feel I feel
like sometimes a wolf whistles are going
to come at me and then I'm gonna be
triggered and then it's just gonna be
horrific
but I you know I just manage it I just
manage it Dave and the sad thing is is
that this is extremely patronizing woman
and you know what we have fought for
equality why are we showing away this
takes if this takes three steps
backwards this is ridiculous and the
thing is with modern-day feminine
feminism like I said it doesn't support
mens need as well if we want gender
rights for one gender equality we have
to consider things that they aren't
addressing now from what I previously
stated the patriarchy now feminists like
to consider it an oppressive force on
females and they like to paint it on
Western females as well not just those
that are generally oppressed
no I would say the patriarchy is doing a
bloody bad job at benefiting the
oppressors if we look at the endemic of
male suicides for instance if we look at
the rates of of male to female ratios of
going into university especially in the
UK it's atrocious and I can't help but
feel that these modern-day feminists are
fighting battles out already won in the
in the in the West you know you know
what I pet a newspaper here in the UK
the Guardian I'm sure you're a big fan
of these and those those lovely articles
yeah a little regressive for me but
every now and again there's something
okay exactly there's always like a
fairly good discussion on it's like a
diamond in the rough but the most part
it has become sort of clickbait guess
what we're going to appropriate today
what sexist today how can I be a victim
today and it's so disempowering you know
I want to read articles about women
making it in the world which we do which
we do because we are equal to men and we
should be so proud of it
so why are we shying away from that why
are we teaching these students that you
know men are horrible creatures which is
something I detest because we are equal
and when I say equal we are not the same
because we are biologically different
and again we should be so proud of that
we should be proud that we fill each
other's differences we complement each
other it's a wonderful thing
yeah all right so we got a pause there
cuz you're giving me a lot I love it you
know I know I'm on board most of these
ideas and you know what I promise you
I'm gonna send this to Christina
directly so she can listen to this
lovely but so when you talk about these
ideas it's very obvious to me you're not
just telling me this this is something
you talk about in your in your life as
well when you talk about this either at
university or with your friends are you
tion have you been fighting with people
what's going on I've been told to check
my privilege because I'm apparently I'm
not oppressed enough I'm not oppressed
enough as a woman I'm you know and
apparently there are other woman out
there in the West that has suffering
from the patriarchy that I am yet to be
aware of I think they should also talk
to them
working-class ex coal miner in Yorkshire
who is currently suffering and it can
barely afford his counsel flat and tax
you know so if these it's like describe
logic and they don't see this and I can
totally I can totally empathize with
what they're trying to do that they're
trying to find some good they're trying
to do something I can see the intentions
but good intentions don't always mean
good results you know yeah the road to
hell is paved with good intentions
exactly
and um like you say I do get why they
shunned I don't want to be victimizing
myself or you know i'm so triggered by
talking about this those good move there
you could have went that route but i got
out that was good but in a sense there
is a wall I'll give them videos and say
Christina's talks or you know I'll link
them I dare not link them tomorrow yet I
adore him but I feel like they won't get
him quite yet baby steps you know sure
I'll link them say peer-reviewed studies
suggesting perhaps that you know and the
pay wage gap has nothing to do with a
mystical patriarchy but is nearly to do
with job preferences as one of the
factors and they all just dismiss it as
saying oh it's just a one-off case but
how many one-off cases can you use as an
excuse for that it's it's you know straw
Manning to say the least and they're
trying to fight a battle which has
already be won as many as christine has
a reset many times yeah so do you think
that goes to the you know the feelings
over facts idea that seems to be what
comes out of unfortunately a lot of the
left these days it is sad and it's it's
sad because as much as we use the
regressive left mean trope so to speak
and it's very true it's very true I
trying not to think that it's most the
left because you know I'm very much a
liberal and ideas I believe it you know
I believe in a quality I believe in gay
marriage I believe all of that and I
believe in freedom of expression I
believe in exchange of ideas and I truly
believe with freedom of it with free
exchange of ideas you can you can fight
you can empathize the people you can see
why people think the way they think and
there's there's less hatred there's
tension because you're able to
understand one another which is
ultimately an amazing thing to do in
such a globalized world
um and it's hard to do that when you
just focus solely on emotion and not
logic or rationality because then you
can misinterpret something you can say
it's racist you can say it's bigoted
when it's perfectly an innocent
statement it's probably a certain
statistic that is suddenly magically
turned out to be racist
man you're you are preaching you my
logic or something
is mango that one I think you could be
my new co-host wait I want I want to
shift to one more with you so you
mentioned in your submission that there
is a form of atheism also that you don't
like and now I've had a lot a theists on
here I'm generally I'm Pro atheist and
I'm Pro logic and reason and all that
stuff but you think that there's that
some of the movement so to speak has
taken a turn that you don't like can you
tell me about that
so of course I'm making myself a huge
fan of the secular movement I think we
are very very fortunate to be living you
know mostly a secular world with
exceptions and I'm glad we are doing a
lot of work towards fixing that however
I do think there is a sinister smugness
in the Atheist movement and I do think
it's connected to some of some of the
far left because I'm it's very
interesting how some of these people
swap say religion for their own ideology
a fervent ideology based on the
patriarchy or based on imaginary things
and it's very religion like so in an
Internet in an essence somewhat sunny
swapping religion and I'm not anti
religion I might be atheist but I'm not
anti religion at all I think there's
ought to be said for some of the
cultural things at the Anglican Church
the United Kingdom has given us culture
it's given us art it's given us an
explosion of things we can't deny
totally here exactly and so one must be
careful when criticizing a belief which
is totally fine and not the believer and
benefits of what that belief has given
us but I do also think that some of
these people go go a very Marxist route
so they do believe that religion is the
opiate of the people say and they
completely exchange logic and reason for
their own ideology so it's not like
they're an atheist that has become an
atheist because they've discovered
science or they've you know read more
Dawkins they've become an atheist sort
of as a result of the ideology through
the cultural Marxism that is being
perpetuated in a lot of the academia
nowadays that's that's how I'm that's
why I'm worried about that route but for
the most part you know I'm I'm perfectly
perfectly am joyous a secular movement
so that's that's fine with me yeah all
right well is it this went by super fast
clearly I know we could we could have
talked a lot more I'm curious what do
you want to do with your life because
obviously you have a lot to say and I do
get that voice out there
that's that's very kind of you and I
have a lot of I'm gonna start my own
business I'm quite ambitious actually
and I'm just finishing up my final
University so I'll be um freed from the
shackles soon enough but I'm gonna have
a think about what I'm going to do
actually I'm going I think that because
this is actually this has been a
pleasure actually thank you so much for
having me on the show
alright I'm on with John from Turkey
that John it's spelled CA n but as I
know that the C in Turkey is a J that is
that all I need to know about your
alphabet there's a couple other things I
should probably know right I'm probably
buddy's pretty much easy yeah he's
pretty yeah alright well we have a lot
to talk about because we've talked a bit
about Turkey on the show and you sent us
a great email with explaining some of
your frustrations with Turkey some of
the good things with hurricane we're
hearing a lot about Turkey in the news
right now for a series of reasons so I'm
going to start it there give me just the
general state of things in Turkey right
now
well the like Kentucky is tough but I
can say that it's relatively easy than
living in an outer predominance of
countries in the region but there are
still replies on human rights violation
pressure on Free Press pressure on free
thinkers and we also have a massive
refugee crisis and is create sacred
problems economical and social problems
and also we have a really polarized
country like the there are many
different social and cultural groups
that have different lifestyle different
values and expectations from life and
finally we have what can I say we have a
internal conflict for them more than 40
years between the Kurds and Turks and it
blurs the line between the Islamists and
the secular like it makes a slice and
some secular toast stand together
against curse so I assume you are you
totally secular are you an atheist are
you religious are you Muslim some
combination thereof no I made this and
I'm totally secular I'm for sexual and
different rallies yeah that's that's it
can you be openly atheist openly secular
there because it sounds like the Prime
Minister has sort of been cracking down
or he's making the country more Islamist
in a sense while he tries his best and
he has a great support during his being
winning every single election that he he
was getting into he has been getting
into for 14 years he has half of the
votes every time yeah and also we have
another instance and nationalist party
in the parliament and white but I can
also say that we have roughly one-fourth
of the population that is sector and for
secular values they have secular
lifestyles there are many is Ezell it's
always said that turkeys 90% percent
mine Muslim and that kind of stuff but I
think it's less than this and it's must
incur me any of this community is
getting bigger and bigger that bigger
every day and people are understanding
that secular values are really important
for us
yeah so that's really interesting
because you know we hear from people in
the West all the time they always use
Turkey as the example of sort of like
you know a good Muslim country you know
yeah because you're okay you can do this
you have no fear about being on this
show right you can do this and you're
not I mean I know that Iran is cracking
down on the press but do you yeah I do I
can't I don't know if is okay to say but
I don't know well like sometimes I feel
like if I need some certain stuff I can
my job some certain things can go badly
and the kind of stuff so but at the same
time I wanna I want to become I want to
be open and I wanna share my ideas and
values and I want to stand for these
families for my country and for for the
entire universe especially yeah well I
love that that's exactly why I do the
show so let's talk a little bit about
the immigration situation because
obviously you guys you share a border
with Syria it sounds like at some level
a lot of the European fighters for Isis
come through Turkey to get there then
you guys get the refugees then as you
said you there's also this issue with
the Kurds who are sort of caught in the
middle and being fought on by by both
Isis and Turkey so what's the general
situation as far as like integrating the
immigrants are they staying in Turkey
are they just using Turkey to go to the
rest of Europe what's going on
well there's there's literally no
integration because I mean millions of
people keep coming to Turkey and you
cannot shut down the border you cannot
just say that you are not welcoming you
so we have to accept them but they're
coming five Millions
and like down the streets and there's a
lot of social problems like a lot I see
I started seeing in different cities in
our Tolia like fabulous tweeds like
people living on the streets and refugee
camps and that kind of stuff and also
I'm going to say that like people say to
you but truth is a really big company
for example Syrian border is roughly a
thousand tomato event for me mm-hmm so I
don't see that I don't feel that effect
of Isis and the kind of Bubba cities in
the bottom the border suffer the most
mm-hmm yeah yeah so you also wanted to
talk about the regressive left of course
I'd say out of our out of our 1200 out
of our 1,200 emails I'd say about a
thousand did to have the phrase
regressive left so how has this
regressive ideology affected your life
in Turkey well whenever I'm here very
invested talking on any TV show on
YouTube like blood rushing to my head
and my office start sweating I keep
getting angry and angry because down
telling lines like they're telling
stupid stories about Turkey I understand
countries for example that that harmony
men they say Turkey is the Harmony are
between settlers and an Islam face
perfect country I mean whenever someone
criticizes them they say it's the
perfect example and you say all Muslims
but here is too deep it some name to
align so you're a bigot you're in
Istanbul but there
are much different than that I mean
there is a struggle between essentialist
and the sliced and it's not just they
and whenever you see like something
about a a drawn on on the media it's
presented like he's holding us as
hostages like there's a dictator and
he's doing whatever you want he has a
huge support from society I mean 50
percent of people suppose it loves love
him interpretation support and love him
so but at the same time we have secular
so it's just a constant battle between
us so it's not just a a harmonious
coexistence
yeah and regresses keeps telling lies
about it and you know I wanna say
something wrong for example I always see
some mister guys speaking with
confidence about truth in Islam like
vulnerabilities and that kind of stuff
then I see people from the left in the
Western countries while cherishing the
Western values the most and they start
talking cowardly being incapable of
defending universal around so I can't
get it what's wrong with you on what
what's wrong with these liberals in the
West I mean I wish I knew what was wrong
with them because it would solve a lot
of my personal problems I I mean I don't
know so but how big is that ideology
they're like so you have you have the
Islamists now okay we get what they're
about and then you have the secularists
how big is that that piece that is this
sort of regressive thing in secular well
how big is the regressive part that's
sort of trying to quiet on secular
because we know that the Islamists are
trying to quiet the secularists right
well you know we don't have the we don't
have enough comfort to be regressive
right we don't have any aggressive in
our country but regresses keep helping
the Islamists in the West and they do
much chairman of us I mean the guys in
Bangladesh in Saudi Arabia again in many
Middle Eastern countries they are
to death by machetes and people keep
talking about I mean over wearing a bow
ties is it arrived what is that or
people's to keep talking about being a
trunk mister and that kind of stuff I
mean this really makes me angry because
people are fighting for freedom here and
people like that they're losing their
lives and then I see people living in
counter than : people even people like
me it's comical
I've been called by a Westerners
islamaphobe for many times even though
I'm living in Turkey I was born in -
right you're you're living in it they're
living in the in the comforts of the
West and they're calling you in Islam
folk listen man we could we could go on
forever we could go on forever here but
unfortunately we got to keep rolling but
it was really it was a pleasure talking
to you and thank you for taking me out
of 1,000 people thanks for submitting
alright we'll talk again alright I'm on
with Bashir in Jordan Bashir how's it
going doing well thank you
thank you for having me yeah oh so my
pleasure I'm doing great all right so
you're the third one up we're dancing
across the globe here you know Jordan
one of the things when I saw your email
you're actually the only person from
Jordan that emailed and we never really
hear anything about Jordan you hear
about the Middle East constantly every
day in the news something terrible's
happening in the Middle East but Jordan
you don't hear much the King comes here
and he has a nice suit and looks good
and everything that that's pretty much
all you hear about Jordan so tell me a
little bit what's going on in Jordan
well yeah um I think Jordans like this I
of the storm and when you have a storm
nobody speaks about the eye of the storm
because doesn't do anything so all the
damage is happening all around us but
Jordan is pretty safe and nothing really
happens except we keep taking in
refugees from all over mm-hmm and the
latest numbers have looked at almost a
third of Jordans populations actually
refugees including my family we came
from Palestine after the you know the
first
issues with Israel yeah after the Second
World War so yeah my family's included
in that number men are you do you have
full rights to Palestinians and Jordan
have full rights
I thought they can't they can't vote in
certain things or have certain jobs or
something well that's a tough one
there's there's so many regulations so
my family has been here from the start
so I'm kind of okay but Palestinians
who've come later do have some issues
especially with like you said and the
legal system they're not fully protected
yeah so speak yeah how do you feel in
terms of so you you emailed me you're
doing this right now like just in the
general terms of being able to speak
your mind and not worry about government
coercion or anything like that like you
feel pretty comfortable
um I think I do I stopped really
bothering with it too much it's start
you know it was really difficult to
start speaking out eventually you find
your own circles and at some point
there's a tipping point we just don't
care anymore about the consequences
you're you just fight for you know what
you think is right and this is one of
the reasons I love your show I love you
and I admire you for what you're doing
Thanks all right so you gave me a bunch
of great stuff to talk about here one of
the things you wanted to focus on was
the Western apologists for Islam now
obviously it obviously I have spent a
lot of time talking about it right and I
always try to separate you know the the
Muslim people from the doctrine of Islam
it's very hard to do as we know but yeah
go ahead the Western apologist you're in
a Muslim majority country having to live
under certain laws dictated by Islam so
what do you make of these people in the
West that are apologizing for this well
well I'll just start out by saying like
even your distinction is sometimes a bit
blurry like even when you separate
Muslim people's add the doctrine of
Islam I think there's still some muddy
areas in between sure I'm
sure all of us want to be nice and
peaceful but at the same time when
you're in a conflict and you expect the
other side to be as nice as you that's I
think of it silly
you don't walk up to a lion with a
flower expect yeah they'll be friends
forever right oh yeah it doesn't work so
the Western apologist is my problem with
them is by focusing on they misdirect
the problems and the issues and as if
it's like now it's not as bad you know
I'm sure like people like Reza Aslan and
the Young Turks sorry for bringing that
up but what they practically do is the
the effect on the good people like
yourself and but the classical liberals
or whoever is genuinely caring about
what's happening in the Middle East and
the Muslim majority countries they take
the conversation away and it alleviates
this sense of urgency they just kill it
like if you wanted to help and then you
hear someone who claims to be a scholar
and like he knows everything on the
inside and they tell you that no it's
all fine then you just think yeah I
don't feel the urge to help anymore and
for us on the inside we see this almost
on a daily basis I mean female genital
mutilation homophobia and all the
terrible things people just genuinely
dislike in the West these are real
problems and we would appreciate the
help from you know from everybody who
can help right so in a way so you're
you're in like a particularly I guess
tenuous situation because you're you're
clearly your I assume you identify as a
classical liberal or a liberal or some
Western ish something you stand for
basically Western values I sense right
and and you you sort of need the help of
the outsiders to make change there
because it would be very hard to do on
your own right well you know of course
the help would be much appreciated but
when there's what's the opposite of help
they're just not helping at all and
they're actually making everyone else
feel like there's no problem yeah you
think there's no problem then well what
are you gonna do the problem is gonna
keep on escalating until it just blows
up so I don't I read it's it's a tough
question I think because I mean sure
that help would be needed but you know
not ruining it for us would be also
appreciated right so on a day to day
basis living in Jordan like how much is
religion affecting well are you
religious at all do you have any
religious I'm not yeah I'm not so how
much religious religiosity religiosity
what's the word there how much of that
are you yeah I think I got something
close how much of that is affecting your
day-to-day life
well my day-to-day life isn't really a
problem for me but if you look at other
segments of society like women or
homosexuals or it you know any kind of
traditionally marginalized group because
Jordans still a very patriarchal society
I'm like what feminists in the u.s. want
to tell you right right yeah so I mean
being a woman if you walk down the
street you're expected to be dressed
appropriately which is pretty much
covered up and it's not really strict
like in Saudi Arabia where you have to
wear the veil it's not like that but
like don't show legs or you know so it's
kind of moderate in that sense the
religiosity is pretty much everywhere
like you always see these verses from
the Quran or somewhere in the streets
you always hear the call to prayer five
times a day so and it's part of our
language we always say like you might
have heard this phrase inshallah of
course so yeah Allah the prophet always
come into these traditional phrases we
don't probably mean it to be religious
but it's just ingrained in us mm-hmm and
yeah it's just inescapable really but I
mean it's not as bad as
swear so that's some hope for us yeah
well this was quick wait we're basically
wearing this the same shirt I just
realized it's pretty close oh so we're
we're in good company listen I could go
way longer with you but we got to go
your third out of out of 20 but it was a
pleasure talking to you and let's stay
in the loop and I hope to get Jordan one
day well you're always welcome great
thank you so much don't tell us you're
gay though yes we'll keep it quiet we'll
keep it quiet Dori all right I'm here
with Felix in Germany Felix you dressed
for the occasion finally somebody that's
looking sharp that's nice to see thank
you I mean you always dressed very well
so I thought I'd dress up for the
occasion as well very nice you you
one-up me with the tie next time maybe
I'll see what I can do all right so we
got a lot of responses from Germany I'd
say after probably the United States UK
maybe Canada and then India I think
Germany was right there in the top five
so you're the one that we selected from
Germany so tell me what's going on in
Germany these days I mean the biggest
thing is obviously the refugee crisis
and the whole political fear that is
surrounding that so kind of our polit
politics is in kind of trouble because
we have people who don't agree with the
stablished politicians and established
politicians fighting each other so it's
really interesting times yeah so we've
talked about it a little bit basically
you guys have led in about 1.3 million
immigrants or migrants or refugees
whatever you want to call them you guys
give them some pretty great social
services right it seems like they get a
lot so what what is the problem what is
is there an integration problem is it
more from the German side is it from
their side is it both is it economics
what's going on see if I would say it's
not a problem with either the German
locals on the migrants or refugees
themselves it's a problem with systems
the government let in all these
immigrants who are not necessarily all
refugees because there's really no
proper control who gets in and who
doesn't and
they saw later in a process that takes
months until the whole asylum
application goes through and then we
take in 1.3 million of them but there's
no system to give them shelter
effectively to integrate them to teach
them about the German culture so what we
get is a lot of people bunched up in a
really small place who come from
different cultures than our home culture
and then form their own little
subcultures and don't integrate very
well because they have nobody to really
talk to except for their own people yeah
so does Germany have sort of a special
place in this because of the history
with Germany and obviously xenophobia
and World War two and Germany has done a
tremendous amount to repair that and the
culture has completely changed I think
that's very obvious but that there's a
certain amount of guilt that so you want
to do the right thing and then they come
here and then the the systems as you're
saying are just not in place so it's
like the idea doesn't quite match up
with the reality of what's going on
that's exactly what's happening I mean
in Germany we have a certain type of
unique political correctness and that we
really still have the shame of the guild
I want to want to redeem ourselves
basically even though we are almost two
generations removed from the events but
most Germans still feel the need to be
proper to other people and to help out
others so there is this goodwill of
helping these people and naturally
people who come from civil war ridden
areas that is a human feeling of you
have to help them out but I think the
way we are doing it now is really
failing those people in need and I've is
also failing the people locally in
Germany yes so let's talk a little bit
about what happened on New Year's Day in
Cologne because I thought that was sort
of a perfect example of why this whole
debate is so crazy so there were these
mass attacks that mostly it sounds like
they were mostly done by migrants
assaulting women there were rapes and
all this stuff and I saw the reaction of
the left here immediately was saying
this is Islamophobia and all of this
stuff that we we talk about endlessly
and really it didn't have anything to do
with that if a grew if any group had
attacked all a bunch of women I would
have been against that group how was the
reaction in Germany to that because it
sounded like it it took a couple days
for it actually to catch on right then
people didn't really want to talk about
it well it almost took a few weeks
because the fact that those groups who
assaulted women where mainly immigrants
was hidden away from the public
essentially by political officials and
police and the reaction was quite
interesting because people were really
afraid and really angry about the
situation and some on the left that the
same as leftists in an America and try
to put it away from Islam as a religion
or culture and then on the right a lot
of people blamed Islam or Muslims in
general for that which is obviously also
way too extreme but kind of the center
is missing where we acknowledge the
problem that there are cultural
differences and if you put young males
who come from this culture have been
growing up in this culture put them in a
place and just let them have their their
own communities without any integration
that these problems can occur and will
cure and that's where we have no
solution for because we can't
acknowledge the problem yeah
so with everything you've said so far do
you guys have a particular sort of fear
of the right-wing parties growing
because because of the history of your
country that you don't want these
xenophobic people to actually take power
and then at the same time as we talked
about all the time if the left doesn't
deal with these issues honestly it
almost seems like the average person the
person that's in the middle that you're
talking about well then they go to where
the only answer is being spoken of even
if it's not something they agree with
that's exactly right and that's what
we've been seeing I mean there's always
a move from the established politicians
to ban these few very right-wing parties
that we still have in Germany which are
really extreme at least some of them are
and they always try to ban them via the
legal system but now what the Eternity
for Germany the AFD and Germany that's a
new party has sprung up in all this
controversy and they've become very very
big and a lot of people jump onto that
opportunity but at the same time a lot
of right-wing extremists obviously
jumped on that and the established
politicians all try to paint this new
party which is more conservative more
right-wing into the Nazi corner to
isolate them but what then it of course
happens is that you get a lot of
extremists to join that party and you
don't find the real discourse yeah so
one of the things that you wrote that I
thought was really really great so first
off you're starting a podcast with the
Hungarian friend is he is he in Germany
or easy and Hungary or somewhere else so
he's in Hungary we've in person we've
only met once when I was at a time we
connected through the Internet's just by
chance I met him one day and we started
talking and talking and talking and
because we both felt the need to speak
out about politics about philosophy
about our societies and to discuss how
we can make them better we started
having night long discussions literally
through the night until the Sun came
back up and at some point we through
shows like yours where you really
emphasizing the need to make your voice
heard we decided we have to do something
and we decided to basically start a
podcast to get other people in to
discuss that stuff with us and to
develop our opinions openly and to kind
of make a difference
yeah well listen I love that and if
every single person that watched this
show started their own show and I became
completely irrelevant but the idea is
one I would be I'll be happy to retire
on a farm in Wyoming or something so one
of the phrases that you used in your
email to us was the difference between a
global network and a local network and I
thought this concept was really cool
because it's very much what we're doing
here and it's why I wanted to do this
fan show and we have 20 people I think
in 18 countries or so or 15 countries so
can you describe what you meant by that
that concept so a lot of our local
network
like university schools but cities and
even countries are very isolated we we
have a consensus usually in in those
networks in universities in America for
example you have all the social justice
various having a real consensus and a
lot of power yeah so you can I think as
a modern human you can't rely on that to
get a full picture
so these global networks that are
enabled by the Internet are really where
ad where you can get your ideas
challenged where you can get new ideas
where you can exchange ideas and that's
where you develop the good stuff yeah
well I love that it's very much a
concept that I believe in and that I'm
trying to put into action and we got to
go but definitely let me know when the
podcast is up just email us again I'll
be happy to send people over there
and I'll be a guest if you want how
about that oh that would be amazing it's
actually up now we're episode four now
nice and you can find that and uh
needlessly complicated comm on iTunes
and everything else and if you want to
be also I'm happy to I guess I am happy
to send you an email you be the host
I'll be the guest how about here all
right so I am with Monica in Paris
France
and Monica you know I got a zillion
people that emailed from Paris but your
bio your bio just where you bounced
around from a little bit of your
family's history there was so much there
that you were the winner from Paris oh
cool yeah thanks alright so first off
just tell me so you told me that you
grew up with two atheist parents but
that that was also colored with a
Mexican tradition and a Jewish tradition
can you just explain some of that yeah
so my mom is from Mexico she's from a
city to the north of Mexico City and she
immigrated to the United States as a
baby and my dad is of Russian Ashkenazi
descent and they both met in university
they've always been atheist both of them
and they raised me and my sister not to
be atheist but religion has never played
a part of our lives yeah and yeah we
were raised between the two cultures
which was quite difficult growing up in
Arizona in California we were never
Mexican enough to be Mexican never
like white enough to be white yeah does
an interesting experience I'm very
grateful for it yeah that's really cool
so then you bounced around pretty much
all over the world so can you give me
like a one-minute synopsis of just where
you've bounced around and then we'll dig
into some of the things that you want to
talk about yeah sure so I lived in
Argentina for about a year in 2012 after
that um I lived in Israel for a while
and now I live in France yeah so I've
lived in a few different countries ok so
let's go to some of the reasons that
you've bounced around so you met an
Israeli and you moved to Israel and then
you were there during the Gaza war of
2014 I think yeah there during
protective edge protective edge so tell
me a little bit about what it's like to
be in a country that is at war it was
really scary so I still remember the
very first time I heard a missile I was
watching a show on my laptop and I heard
an explosion and I didn't really think
anything of it then I heard more
explosions and then there were sirens
and I had no idea what to do I was
living in a small house that didn't have
a bomb shelter so um I ran outside my
neighbors told me to run in to bomb
shelter next door and I I couldn't have
known but then after that for then
following months it just became the norm
like at least minimum seven times a day
I would found myself in a bomb shelter
and I was an English teacher at the time
and a lot of our class time was spent
learning in bomb shelters yeah so what's
that like being around kids when this is
happening I mean you're literally I
assume every school there probably has a
bomb shelter right like yeah
so the middle of day you're teaching and
then suddenly we all have to run
downstairs yeah so the kids know the
drill the kids are eerily desensitized
to it there it's just the norm for them
you know inside the bomb shelters we
have teaching materials and it was like
everything just kind of kept going like
normal for them just part of their
everyday yeah so then okay so you were
there for that and then you moved to
Paris and you were in Paris during the
Paris attacks right yeah so Charlie
Hebdo happened just months after me
arrived
and my initial reaction was
disappointment because I left Israel to
kind of get away from all that danger
and then I found myself in the middle of
it again I was shocked I was really I
felt really angry and then the way
people reacted to an attack like that in
Paris was so different than the way
Israelis would have reacted so that's
one of the things that I thought was
really interesting so you mentioned that
that basically a lot of people said oh
we're defending Charlie Hebdo but that
really privately that's not really what
they were doing right yeah so there was
like a protest where people went out in
the street and they were like holding up
pencils and I I didn't want to
participate in anything like that
because I'm just thinking like the
people who shot these cartoonists and
shot these artists we're not trying to
take away their pencils like they were
trying to kill them it has nothing to do
with your ability to write or draw
cartoon like they want to murder people
so I just felt like the reaction was
very soft and just very different than
the Israeli reaction would have been so
what would the Israeli reaction be I
mean they're dealing with the ctrio
everyday Israeli I think we all know
what the Israeli act reaction would have
been it would have been something um but
probably most of the world wouldn't have
been very happy with yeah that most of
the world would protest against and
something that I would have protested
against before I lived in Israel when I
went to Israel I was I wouldn't have
described myself as pro-israel but now I
would this is just very different when
you have missiles flying over your head
and if it wasn't for that um Iron Dome
interception system you know they could
just fall on your head and kill you and
all your friends and family so it
changed my perspective completely yeah
interesting so okay so then you were
there for Charlie Hebdo then then the
more recent attacks yeah at the theater
how has that changed Society because it
does seem like that attack and then
Brussels and then we had the thing here
in San Bernardino that now there is some
piecing of this all together across the
globe and I think it really felt like it
started with that one
I'm from San Bernardino by the way
really
yes I'm getting very close to home for
me man you really are yes okay okay um
so the most recent attack was very
unsettling um same my I had the same
feeling towards the French reaction that
I did for Charlie Hebdo kind of just
disappointment and the lack of I don't
know of like strong reaction it was more
just like a soft reaction that we have
to protect people who haven't even been
insulted yet everybody was just worrying
about hurting a certain group of
people's feelings instead of actually
trying to get to the root of the problem
yeah um how deep is that how deep is
that feeling in France that because that
I mean that's what we talk about we talk
about this regressive ideology that we
care more about feelings over facts how
much has that sort of seeped into
society over there I would say probably
even more so than in America people here
are very concerned about being
politically correct in a country that
has a very high percentage of north
africans and muslims people are very
careful to choose their words the media
is very careful about what they say and
how they say it which is a good thing
and a bad thing um but I would say that
now things have kind of died down
honestly people have kind of forgotten
about it security is very lacks
everywhere um they still have some like
emergency procedures in place ever since
Charlie Hebdo so it's been almost two
years that we've had these emergency
procedures they're supposed to be in
place but like private and public
security and France is just not where it
should be yeah so the other thing that I
wanted to talk to you about or that you
mentioned is that there's there's two
things happening in France right now so
one is is the immigration situation so
you have all these migrants coming in
and then at the same time basically
Jewish emigration from France so Jews
leaving France is at an all-time high I
was actually in Israel in November and
heard a tremendous amount of French
being spoken there I couldn't believe I
mean there were signs in French all the
places that were selling houses were
written in Hebrew and in French so
what's going on there so I can't speak
too much about the immigration of
refugees to France because honestly we
hear about it on the news but it doesn't
affect me at all I don't see them
it just doesn't play a role in my life
so I can't really speak on that but um I
have been very involved in the French
Jewish community so I know how they feel
about the situation in France and in
Israel so there's kind of this feeling
in the French Jewish community I don't
want to say I'm not a victim hood but
they're very closed network of people
like in the Paris Area and um they
always feel targeted and they feel like
Israel is kind of like this Eldorado
it's like this thing that they idolize
and it's like this ideal utopia that
they all want to strive to be a part of
so every time there's an attack it's
like the percentage of French Jews that
leave France just skyrockets um but then
another interesting phenomenon is that
when I was in Israel I meant so many
people who leave Israel after intending
to settle there just like I did right
there's actually a word in Hebrew for
that it's called yareta so alia is when
you immigrate to Israel to go live there
supposedly forever right and there's
even a word to describe leaving there
forever because you just can't handle
the quality of life so French people
encounter that they leave hoping to find
this network of acceptance and like
living amongst Jews just going to be
amazing
and then they get there and realized
that they were kind of sold a dream and
a lot come back yeah so it's sort of
like the grass is always greener you
have it one way and you think okay it's
going to be better over there yeah all
right well you you've given me a lot and
we're plowing through all these
interviews but it was a pleasure talking
to you and and good luck with the rest
of your adventures thank you so much
you